Love Actually is actually live how much
fun is it doing this show because we
were just saying if you're rehearsing
you're doing this show tonight how much
fun and how exhausted are you well
exhausted at the moment but like we're
in the thick of it but it's really you
know for me Love Actually is one of my
favorite films of all time so not even
Christmas movie like top 5 maybe I mean
it's like you know not the most like
artistic film but it's like it's my
heart for some reason so to be doing it
right now is really thrilling and to
present it the way that we're doing has
been like such a wonderful experience
and you know you get to see that movie
on stage every night it's just perfect
[Music]
definitely having this show going on I
know sort of like lights up the
Christmas heart a little bit I got asked
you hmm
how happy are you Steven your own love
life because I saw a pretty cute picture
on Instagram ah the one of my dogs the
one of a beautiful lady and you said
she's a gift to you every day violet my
dog Jenna oh I am I'm very happy at the
moment it's a good it's a good holiday
right now so I'm it's a good Christmas
this year well does that mean you guys
are spending Christmas together I'll be
working okay well let me ask you that
when you say something like everyday
with you as a gift that's a pretty
amazing powerful statement that makes a
woman think I wanna hear a guy say that
about me what makes you say that about
Jenna
you can giggle about us through this
okay we love ya it's a very good holiday
this year it's okay you know my birthday
is October 30th so I get sort of
Halloween birthday Thanksgiving
Christmas it's been perfect this year
that's all I can say so it sounds like
your life with a certain Sun was pretty
perfect right violet is amazing well let
me ask you one last question
could this beautiful lady Jenna of
course come see the show will she be in
the audience awareness she may be I
don't know I'd have to I don't know I'll
have to see you know I really I don't
know she's a very busy person she's got
a lot going on well she's a performer
too I mean if you guys bonded over that
because she does so much onstage dancing
she does that everything she's a dancer
well you're welcome for et being history
okay so you're very happy right now
uh-huh because Jenna told us she was
very happy she suppose she did say that
to do that do you want to talk about new
love are you happy
because we love you so we want you to be
happy yes I'm very happy thank you for a
very happy person in general I think
thanks to you okay so you might sing if
you have special lady in your life you
might say don't give up a new talent
Steve and you also just want to say give
the people a pitch why should they come
see that actually well I think you
should just come and see these
tremendous actors and voices in a show
it's Christmas and I think the show
absolutely sets us off in that perfect
way for the holidays everyone should
come out check it out it's gonna be a
great time three adjectives describing a
physical law student in school with an
adjective joyous as a heartfelt yeah
we'll take it make you feel warm and
fuzzy put me on the spot next of
you